and remember kids kakashi Wars masks for
500 episodes spanning over five years
you can wear a mask for a few darn
months
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
brought to you today in partnership with
Full Sail University you know among
anime series fewer have been more
culturally omnipresent than burritos
Dada and it's not hard to see why ninjas
are just inherently cool and Naruto
struck a sweet balance of comedy and
action with the cast of characters that
many of us grew to love and boy did we
get to spend a lot of time with those
characters the show has been running in
one form or another for over 20 years
that's 700 plus episodes of run time and
running is one of the things that this
series is synonymous with because across
all that time all those characters and
all the memes asking why Kakashi's mask
doesn't burn when he breathes fire one
of the most memorable parts of the show
is in fact the running arms back body
forward now you're running like a real
ninja and while this running form
certainly existed long before its
appearance on Naruto it was the first
anime to truly popularize the concept in
the cultural vernacular and thus it came
to be known as the Naruto run with it
really blowing up in 20 19 BC that's um
before kovat in case you were wondering
when Naruto runners made national
headlines by trying to infiltrate area
51 such a simpler time anyway the
concept behind ninja running makes
fundamental sense right it conserves
energy rather than waste energy moving
your arms together with your legs or
throwing your body back and forth with
each arm swing leaving your arms
motionless behind you should both
preserve energy and make the running
more efficient other YouTube channels
have covered the science of the Naruto
run in the past including my buddy Kyle
Hill in the show because science all of
them coming more or less to the
conclusion that the run is not only less
effective but also potentially dangerous
to high-performance athletes I on the
other hand disagree it's my theory today
that there is a very solid reason backed
by real world science that the ninjas we
see in Naruto and warriors that we see
throughout all of anime and heck even
Sonic the Hedgehog himself are choosen
to run in exactly this form today we
justify you a strange kid in gym class
who chooses to run this way today we
Sasuke choke the naysayers and
legitimize the Naruto anime run
once and for all real-world sprinters
are a good place to start when it comes
to determining the fastest run times in
races like the hundred meter dash tenths
and even hundredths of seconds make the
difference between gold and silver which
means that if there are tactics to give
even a tiny edge in a race sprinters are
absolutely gonna use them so why then
are they pumping their arms like a noob
and not ninja sprinting like an elite
well a lot of it has to do with balance
whenever you run you're constantly
shifting between putting weight on your
right foot in your left foot your center
of gravity is normally located in
between your two legs which means that
when you're suddenly putting all your
weight on your right leg your body
naturally leans left and when you put
all that weight back on the left leg
your body naturally leans right by
pumping their arms sprinters are counter
balancing the constant shifting of their
center of gravity and that's not all a
study was done at the University of
Houston which looked at various running
positions with non swinging arms crossed
arms hands on head and of course the
Naruto run in each case these alternate
forms increased overall energy
consumption they were less efficient
runners who swung their arms use three
percent less energy relative to those
using the Naruto style in short it seems
like when challenged with actual
real-world science the Naruto run is
done how do you feel about that dad Rudo
cuz people called me a failure I'll
prove them wrong well call me Shikamaru
cuz I'm here to help you do exactly that
you see most of the upsides of the
Naruto run should be in it's more
aerodynamic form the runner is shaped
more like a compact wedge cutting
through the air more effectively than a
normal upright running position this
form in theory is supposed to reduce the
runners overall drag force or huh I
suppose drag foce as I apparently
mistyped it in the script good job Matt
anyway as you run you're constantly
pushing air molecules out of your way
and likewise those air molecules are
resisting against your movement in
whatever small way they can when moving
at low speeds that effect is barely
noticeable right but the effect gets
increasingly higher the faster you go
if you've ever stuck part of your body
out the car window will drive and down
the highway you know what I'm talking
about it's the Naruto run so the
thinking goes reduces drag force because
it reduces your profile meaning
air is hitting you as you run not only
that but it also shapes your body in
such a way as to reduce the coefficient
of drag by making your body more
aerodynamic a study found that runners
who wore more aerodynamic clothing
designed to reduce the drag force on
their body had a teeny tiny advantage
over those who didn't shaving a mere
point zero one seconds off of their
hundred meter dash times that tiny bit
does actually matter after all into 2016
Olympics the difference between the
silver and bronze medallist times was
point zero two seconds as a result many
Olympic sprinters have taken to wearing
aerodynamic Swift suits so again why
aren't they running like a super cool
ninja if every optimization here counts
well the benefit here just isn't worth
it you can wear a swift suit without it
interfering with your overall running
form conversely the tiny tiny benefit
that the Naruto run gives and being more
aerodynamic just isn't enough to offset
the balance problems and increased
energy usage that comes with it humans
just aren't running fast enough to have
drag factor in as a significant problem
and that my friends is where everyone
else is making their mistake when
covering this topic because here's the
thing Naruto and the gang aren't just
normal runners sure for real-world
sprinters drag force is basically
negligible but if you look at some of
the feats of speed that we see
throughout Naruto the ninja start to
look a lot less like real-world Olympic
sprinters and a lot more like
high-performance race cars in other
words they're reaching speeds where the
drag force acting on their body won't be
a significant factor and that means we
have to take a closer look at how drag
would affect the body not of a normal
human sprinter but of a ninja whose
speeds border on the supernatural the
ninjas that we see in Naruto are dodging
laser energy blasts running at speeds
that approach the sound barrier and
dodging attacks that literally have the
word supersonic in the title
those speeds drag force suddenly becomes
a real drag just look at the equation
for drag force now you don't have to
understand any of this right now we'll
get to it in a minute but the one thing
that I want to call out is right here
drag force equals a bunch of things
times V squared that's velocity squared
which means that if you're having an
object moving twice as fast
it doesn't just double the drag force it
wad rules it four times the velocity
means 16 times the drag that is why the
drag force acting on a 25 mile per hour
or 40 kilometer an hour Sprinter can be
so different from the drag force acting
on a race car that reaches 10 times that
amount of speed a study looking at the
effects of wind on runners found that
the equivalent drag force experienced by
a human running at 25 miles an hour or
40 kilometers an hour would be the
equivalent of about 9 pounds of force
just around 40 Newtons far more drag
force than any of us will ever
experience in our lives
since Usain Bolt's the fastest runner
alive is just barely over that mark
taking what we know about drag force
that means that Naruto running with the
same normal upright running form at 250
miles an hour or 400 kilometers an hour
would be experiencing a whopping nine
hundred and thirty pounds of force
acting against him via wind resistance
if he manages to get close to Sonic
speeds at around 750 miles an hour or
1,200 kilometers an hour that drag force
is gonna be magnified to 8,000 370
pounds of force that's not just
impressive speed that requires insane
amounts of strength you literally are
cutting through thousands of pounds of
wind directly blowing against your
forward motion but again all of that is
using a traditional running form if the
Naruto run is indeed able to reduce that
drag force by say light even as low as
10% that would be the equivalent of him
attaching rocket thrusters to his legs
exerting a force of 800 and 37 pounds
propelling him forward so is the Naruto
run making any sort of difference well
let's take a closer look at that drag
force equation again all of this in the
beginning here isn't gonna change
velocity is just how fast we're running
and that little thing looking like a pea
is actually measuring the density of the
fluid that we're running through neither
of which are going to be affected by the
runners form it's really these last two
variables at the end where we can see
the effectiveness or lack thereof of the
Naruto run the area a here is actually
based on the orthographic projection of
the runner which basically just means
it's looking at the area of their front
everything that's hitting the air as you
run a runner can reduce that by wouldn't
you know it crouching down and leaning
forward which is exactly what we see
with the Naruto run just by measuring
his height in different shots we can see
that leaning forward he's effectively
reducing the height of his orthographic
projection and the overall drag on his
body by about 1/4 26% if we're being
exact coefficient of drag meanwhile CD
over here is a bit more complicated to
figure out in fact the real-world method
for calculating coefficient of drag is
usually less about plugging numbers into
an equation and more about looking at
experimental data go figure there just
ain't a lot of real-world data on
fictional supersonic ninjas but we can
at least get a better idea of how much
drag reduction a ninja might be able to
get from leaning forward and trying to
make their body as aerodynamic as
possible by looking at a few comparisons
according to NASA the least aerodynamic
shape was a vertical flat plate and the
most aerodynamic shape was a typical
airplane wing a bullet experiences just
23% of the drag force experienced by the
flat plate and an airfoil experiences a
mere 3.5 percent of the drag experienced
by that flat plate which goes to show
that just by having the right shape you
could reduce the drag force on your body
by as much as 96.5% now simply leaning
forward isn't enough to magically morph
your body into the shape of an airfoil
but studies done on skydivers find that
depending on how you position your body
you can reduce the coefficient of drag
by as much as 30% and that is in
addition to the drag reduction Naruto is
already getting from bending over
factoring both of those into the drag
equation we get ourselves an effective
drag reduction of 48.2% nearly half
which if he's moving at the near
supersonic speeds we talked about
earlier is the equivalent of giving
himself an additional 4,000 335 pounds
of thrust when he runs that is the
equivalent of having two turbo jets
strapped
his body when you look at it from those
numbers there is no doubt that the
Naruto run is the superior running style
for any high speed high performance
ninja of course it kind of goes without
saying that all the people who've done
experiments showing that this style of
running won't help you run faster are
technically right but when you're
dealing with the velocities that we see
in Naruto the seemingly insignificant
factor of drag force suddenly becomes a
lot more significant so while I may have
let down that weird kid in gym class for
his awkward running style sorry my
friend it's not gonna help you I have
just empowered a whole lot of anime fans
in science class to pass their
aerodynamics lesson with flying colors
but hey that's just a theory film theory
and speed of passing classes with flying
colors today's episode is brought to you
by Full Sail University did you ever
wonder why the show looks and feels the
way that does animations flashing across
the screen and a cutout of me rather
than actually standing there with live
action shots well a lot of it has to do
with my skills and equipment back when I
started the channel pop the weekly video
into your web browser I hadn't majored
in filmmaking in college I was a theater
kid through and through and I was too
poor to even afford anything beyond
basic editing software so it was stuck
with a cheap microphone in a tiny closet
and literally no experience I could
envision how I wanted scenes to look
like in my head but I couldn't execute
them in real life so I was left just
doing them in rudimentary animations
over time I've taught myself a lot and
I've gotten a lot more confident in
directing people on real-life sets but
it's still something that I wish I had
greater experience in I still don't know
what to call certain objects on set or
certain shots so I always feel a little
bit awkward which is why if you are
interested in pursuing a career in film
and entertainment
I recommend the sort of training that
Full Sail University provides their film
bachelor's degree program immerses you
in the world of filmmaking giving you
the most important thing for a career in
content creation hands-on experience
even back in my theater days it was
always my belief that knowing all parts
of the production process made you
better at the thing that you wanted to
specialize in and it's the same at Full
Sail University showing you what it's
like to work on every part of a film
from start to finish
they're digital cinematography online
degree program merges the artistic
concepts of traditional filmmaking with
the technical tools that are used in
everything from documentary filmmaking
to commercial production to yes even web
video plus in today's world time and
practical experience are everything and
so these degrees are offered on an
accelerated format to get you into the
field faster making connections and
putting work on your resume that much
quicker with hands-on projects industry
experienced faculty and professional
equipment and sets you'll be prepared to
pursue your passion in no time
Full Sail grads have gone on to work on
some pretty incredible films and TV
shows like Avengers endgame Joker the
mandalorian if you want to find out more
about these film programs and how to get
started visit Full Sail dot edu slash
the film theorists to learn more don't
kid yourself you're not gonna type that
into the URL bar just click the link top
line of the description do it or you
know just call up Full Sail University
and tell them that matpat sent you just
do it I bet not many influencers tell
them to just call up the school and tell
them that matpat sends just to do it
just give them a call with that being
said I'll see you all next week for a
very important video in a very special
announcement